buongiorno scusate accusate stavo
andando a cambiarmi per questa giornata
di allenamento innanzitutto benvenuti
tutti quanti come sempre
partiamo con con la nostra meravigliosa
sigla
[Musica]
[Applauso]
alle 17 ecco qui devo chiamare un attimo
eroga isolato
lo ha detto rita facendo non addentro
queste tutto detto marquez che ha un a
uno scialle in testa noga non l'ho
comprato non lo contro roma che quel
tappetino e allora alla grande con
questa puntata di oggi si è fatto un
punto quello senza il cuscino era
gabriele vestito da donna oggi gabriele
cosa prevede l'allenamento un
allenamento a scopo puramente cronistico
quindi il fisico da comit ok le physique
de comite ricordiamo questo è un
allenamento incredibile che va bene per
tutti ognuno col suo ritmo che ognuno
con il suo fisico da top col suo fisico
da covip
vabbè comunque cabral e io ci sono
muoviti allora nuovo rock per un cretino
facciamo sempre movimenti diversi
cambiamo ci muoviamo perché lo dobbiamo
creare il pelo il tifo da tomic
ok che la muscolatura intelligente
pronto a tutto
i muscoli sono stupidi berlusconi quando
andare allenati si addicono ad un pò
ecco perché abbiamo gli esercizi
cambiati i tempi
noi non vogliamo dei muscoli stupidi
esatto lo vogliamo un fisico da top it
in grado di affrontare di oceanica terrà
la malaria ma tutti i posti nei quali
non possiamo andare esatto quando
potremo no sì no no manuto mangiando è
la caccia note lo facciamo mitare il
bagaglino ma riscaldiamo se uno cambia
molto aggressivo con le ginocchio tu e
la guarda si sta mangiando il kin gara
questo caso di utilizzare investiti a
terra quando carbonara normali io adesso
con con l'energia che ho in mano
potrei darti un pugno in faccia che non
quadra ma come fanno credito sta
allenando bene trophy io sento solamente
kg quindi della sua bocca è riposta
inquadrando solothurn in galera si stava
allenando capitale casa cosa sento un
sacco come si chiama questo mascella
sì ma fare gli esercizi che facciamo noi
e le ragazze sono emerse non si sanno
dici così sono contenti anche i due
bombe di quelli che la testa in giù via
ritiro soccorso avviso non è così male
mi appoggio dormire e forma di tutte le
ragazze coppia moto e poi abbiamo idee
lico ritmi prende solo solo il cielo
ma questo temo che tu sei il 6.26 a kick
out da youtube dagli snack che trova il
pisano di gabrielli queste posizioni di
profilo che in realtà un calzino
[Risate]
balocchi impronta digitale unico tipo
cioccolata l'interno se ci metti addosso
capito ucciderci reati sul trono si
sblocca 10 secondi 6
se hai segnato dai secoli si presti ha
coronato switch qua una scuola via ricco
lento e la prima serie recupero sono una
ricetta ma non i secondi ormai sta
privando che giorno è tempo questo era
il 3 aprile a tamburi
l'arrivo
si no
a me mi scuso legando ormai mitico verso
i casting per quanto un cinema di casa
la gente era una rapa che vengono
montati i figli in quello al casting
quando esso cast i nomi adesso di
onorevoli delfino che conquista la kocca
ritirati i commenti via come di piccole
fiere ma come sto tranquillo la tv ed
equilibro sì che è fin qui non c'è
nessuno grazie
cambia cambiano però anche coordinativi
ottimi metto la mascherina a nessuno
venne a cassino video ne prendo
bravissimi ragazzi a loro il segnale
città cosa serve il legale non hanno
ripreso lo stesso delle città se questo
covit alcune anche dell'abitazione di
guarda gli inganni in città mi ha rotto
un ginocchio è un'altra cosa notevole a
farci recuperare il suo amore
io so dov'è non lo sto facendo bene per
farmi a una gabella e io non sono mai
stato così in forma come da quando sono
costretto a stare a casa via facciamo
stretching che devo far vedere se questa
partita massimo lo stretto di se volete
che definiva serie mutante del file io
prendo dalla punta tira di più se io
spingo indietro fino di più se parliamo
cosa sentire come sa lunga
andava perfettamente a questo il
commento del quale cominciano a morire
loro non capisco perchè a fine lezione
muoia la loro connessione che sta
succedendo bene andiamo avanti intanto
perché è venuto a questo punto capire
questo giusto che cazzola rimasto
davvero ha perso una gamba aveva
sull'altra gamba all'opa con tutto suoni
alla propria e torna perché con un
minuto più così facile
poi va colta in due sulla gamba grazie
qualcuno sa farlo velocemente tetto a
terra giusto petto aterno dai petto a
terra non sia vero e poi per farla
bravissimi ha davanti
ma cerca di andare avanti col petto
eccole breve grandi raga grandissimi non
avrete non sapevo cosa fare
motori allora abbiamo fatto con l'aiuto
anche delle persone che ricordavano i
ragazzi che cosa i movimenti
abbiamo fatto quello va bene io ho fatto
in tempo a una dieta deve essere vista
24 ore per sciogliere tutto conclude
abete devono abbracciare invece dicono
che sembri la nonna di lui tu possa
essere quasi sicuro con la vecchia pista
eventuale paris hilton la clerici ha uno
sguardo magnetico in camera evita che
c'è il regista che sei per primo chiamo
degli occhi lo sguardo che offrirebbe
veramente terrificante
il giochino di dolori quindi raggiunto
idrico di significati semplice
nell'inganno della cadrega
siamo arrivati alla fine fino ad allora
buon weekend e capirci fa un terminale
grazie per la compagnia grazie per gli
allenamenti gabriele ciao buona domenica
ciao ciao ciao ciao ciao ciao con questo
video in diretta dal letto di camere mia
per rispondere a una domanda dove si può
fare il fisico da coliche dove si può
prendere parte alle dirette del figlio
da cofide molto semplice basta mi
seguiate su instagram bojano scilla ogni
giorno dal lunedì al sabato per tutto il
tempo di quarantena alle 17 insieme a
mio fratello va bene ci mettiamo ci
spacchiamo ce lo ritroveremo qui sulle
spalle alla base del collo